if you're going to win this next year in
November 2024 you're not going to win it
talking about what happened last time
haven't you got to sell a positive
message 100 you brought this up to me I
didn't bring it up today you know you
mentioned yourself I said look it was
real and I say that I'll always say that
it doesn't mean that out of a one-hour
speech I'm going to devote half of it to
this except he kind of does I might
devote 10 seconds to it but the election
was rigged it was a rigged election it
was a very dishonest election I don't
know that Nigel farage is correct and
what I mean by that is when you survey
Maga voters
they overwhelmingly believed that it was
rigged when you survey Republican voters
in general
they also to a lesser degree than the
hardcore Maga types but they also have
fallen for this idea that 2020 was
rigged